if you think about it who would have
predicted that a high frequency
amplifier would be useful for eye
surgery high frequency amplifier was
what Charlie towns was trying to build
when he built the Mesa and that ended up
as the laser and now is used in eye
surgery and also in sort of supermarket
checkouts and barcode recognition and
you name it in lots of areas of science
who would have thought that doing radio
astronomy would lead to an experiment
that produced a breakthrough in organic
in organic chemistry so I'm my
experience is that my life has just been
wow this is interesting this is a puzzle
let's just follow it and see where it
leads and it leads to totally unexpected
places by and large and so I that's my
science that's what I seem to be better
at than other things and and I don't
really have a feeling other than to make
some small break through which interests
me and so I'm not good at answering
foretelling the future but then not many
people are actually